where two attorneys argue a case and I
judge Laura make the final ruling
joining me now our attorneys Seth
Behrens wig and Ed Martin all right now
here are the rules a quarter banger each
attorney has 30 seconds to lay out his
case followed by a rebuttal now if the
judge needs more info each of you will
have an additional 30 seconds to explain
in the end I will make my ruling now
first on the docket tonight
it was the Frey festival it was supposed
to be the hottest most exclusive music
festival of a decade
okay now celebrities and models promoted
it online incessantly
[Applause]
all these names
well it's called the fire festival
that's all right the judge sometimes
makes mistakes Bowen hundreds flock to
the private island they were met with
these luxury accommodations looks good
doesn't it and this gourmet food it was
a total disaster
fire the fire organizer mother festival
vessel organizer was sentenced to five
years in prison but what about all the
models in that promo video our kendall
Jenner Bella Hadid and other models
complicit in this fraud now Seth you
have 30 seconds for your opening
argument now let's get the time up on
the clock please go okay the models The
Millionaire models in this case have
been served with the subpoena by a
trustee in the Bankruptcy Court his job
is to collect money and information for
the victims of this fraudulent business
crime the models are upset because they
say that they get paid for the work that
they did and therefore they should be
left alone it's hard to really balance
the hardships in favour of The
Millionaire models who get a quarter of
a million dollars for one tweet so who
deserves the fairness and who deserves
to be able to be inconvenience the
models are the victims I'm on the side
of the victims and I think that the
models need to comply all right Edie
your turn your honor at first I want to
encourage you with that Ruth Bader
Ginsburg listen here's the thing these
models are hired because they are
vacuous people they don't have any sense
of a kind of business or anything else
their job is to put out a tweet to put
their name out they have no idea what's
going on behind the scenes you can't
hold them to any kind of standard
they're barely capable of making
contracts because of their own you know
kind of a pejorative they were in for
just that part of it there that's the
rebuttal the Federal Trade Commission
slammed the models for coming out with
advertisements and tweets for this
without a disclosure that in compliance
with federal law that they were actually
being hired and compensated they're in
trouble with the agency they're in
trouble with the Bankruptcy Court they
deserve comply all right quick read 15
seconds Wow they did what they were
supposed to do they can't be held to any
higher you know anymore than they did
they all right they've got the job done
drooling for Seth and I will say why the
models sent out those tweets they did no
due diligence on the festival that they
were promoting better do due diligence
before you collect your 250,000 next
time Kendall alright now on to the next
Hollywood case hit his ski a listener of
a Lister excuse me Gwyneth Paltrow is
being sued by a man who claims she
smashed into him while skiing knocking
him out leaving him with a concussion
four broken ribs
he says she didn't even stick around she
just left him on the mountain sat in a
chair and I couldn't do anything I
couldn't function and so I get so tired
I go to bed wait a second he's asking
for 3.1 million dollars now this is a
violation of a reckless Ski provision
and that's really is it really worth
that much in damages let's put 30
seconds back on the clock
Edie you may begin your argument well
look this what we have is Gwyneth
Paltrow after she committed this
violation and there's video of this it's
been presented there's descriptions of
what happened she did what a lot of
movie stars do a lot of people that she
went out and bought up all the witnesses
she had people that change their story
the people that ran the resort we just
know that this guy was really hurt you
can see he can barely sleep this guy was
really hurt there was a violation and
she deserves to be sure you should pay
for that Your Honor this case is
ridiculous they were on a bunny slope
you can't pick up so much speed that he
can act like she's slamming him how to
best Sylvester Stallone movie he says
that he had a concussion and a few
broken ribs is that worth 3.1 million
dollars I don't think so I can tell you
how this movie ends he's not going to
get anywhere close to that and she
disputes the fact she says that he hit
her so at the end of the day I'll tell
you he's not going to win anywhere close
to 3.1 he's not entitled to anything
close to that all right I'm going with
Ed on this I'm reducing the judgment to
about $50,000 just because he was you
know he needs acting lessons dollars
gentlemen nice arguments the court is
now adjourned